for those don't know why don't you just
go through some of your background and
then we can kind of talk through how you
got into into the crypto space everyone
I'm Annie co-founder of block stack so I
have a PhD in distributed systems from
Princeton University before entering the
space I basically worked in distributed
systems for those who don't know what
that is
these are the people who have built you
know a lot of the computer networks out
there or the data centers that resulted
in cloud computing and even if you go
back all the way to the 90s people who
build kind of like the first generation
of Internet protocols so that was the
research community that I was part of
and more specifically like the
distributed systems people they'd like
to actually build a real system and then
deploy them and study them so it's not
like a very theoretical part of computer
science
got it and so in that at what point does
the distributed systems work intersect
with blockchain you know kind of this
decentralized crypto ecosystem yeah
that's a good question so I think if you
go back into the 90s you would notice
that there were a lot of efforts that
we're talking about peer-to-peer systems
or designing systems in a way that there
are no single points of failure and in
the 2000s we started seeing and like if
you remember the time of like the
LimeWire or these different file sharing
protocols people were downloading a lot
of like pirated your songs from there
and interestingly at that time the
interest from the top research community
was extremely high like there were lots
of conferences lost people are
publishing papers building systems and
by like 2005-2006 most of that interest
started drying down because they were
warned there wasn't a lot of industry
adoption of the technology and a lot of
the same people and these are people
that are highly respect started moving
into cloud computing and cloud computing
was just starting but companies like
Google or Facebook could actually
bankroll all the research and
development there and you started
noticing how these same kind of like
bright minds were now going to the large
companies and helping them build their
cloud infrastructure
and and in a way the centralization was
a byproduct of that right so these
companies kept becoming bigger and
bigger they started hiring better and
better people and most of the computing
infrastructure and like got centralized
under a few companies got it that that
makes sense and so for you you're at
Princeton right you go in and you get a
PhD and this should be systems at what
point did you kind of discover crypto
and kind of what drew you to what was
going on there
this bunny actually did a search in my
inbox to see when I got exposed to
Bitcoin for the first time this was 2011
I think and then Arvind who is he has a
course on Bitcoin that a lot of people
go through and he also wrote a book
about it
so he's a Princeton professor and he was
just joining at that time amazing and he
set out an email to everyone that I'm
interested in doing research on this
technology I was I marked it as
interesting read later and then my
advisor pinged me that it seems like
something you should really look at and
I was like yeah I've already market I'm
gonna take a look at that and it took me
like more than two years before I
rediscovered some of the technology or
on a completely different path right so
this is me about to finish my thesis but
kind of like decided that I don't want
to go into academia and I started a
company with Ryan Shay my co-founder
that I met at Princeton and it was
basically the team came first and we
knew that we generally want to work on
like core problems with today's internet
but it wasn't really clear what exactly
and and the team came first and we were
starting to work on some of those issues
that hey what's wrong with today's
Internet and how can we make a
meaningful impact and rediscovered
Bitcoin and the blockchain that started
like putting two and two together that
maybe some of these technologies can be
used in different ways and that
eventually became what is it have lost
after they got it and so this is like 13
14 what were some of those early
problems with the internet that you guys
looked and said you know we might not
know exactly what the solution is going
to be but but these are definitely you
know problems that we can identify and
when I go work on yep so let's say
you're a your entrepreneur or developer
and you want to build something
innovative
top of what's available today compare
that to Larry and Sergey back in the 90s
like they could actually write a web
crawler download all the information
they need from the internet and study
the web graph and then innovate on top
of that and build the Google search
engine mmm but if you want to do that
today you can't even get access to the
data that Facebook has or the data that
LinkedIn has a twitter has so we were
trying to do like a get that data and
try to do something interesting with it
but we were getting hit by rate
limitations by Twitter or like Terms of
Service issues with LinkedIn and other
stuff and we started thinking that these
companies are in a way like barrier to
innovation because you need to be
employed at one of these companies to be
able to use the massive like social
graph or information that Facebook is
setting on so if you're not a Facebook
engineer you use almost like I don't
even have a right to innovate I first
need to join the company before I can do
anything with it so so we started
thinking of like how can we make this
information and these social graphs more
decent lines mhm
just like the internet originally was
supposed to be fully decentralized and
open to all the developers got it and so
really what you guys were doing was you
were hitting the walled garden right of
I want access that information that
information could be a resource to me so
I that I can put it together with other
information and resources and if I can
do that correctly then I can I don't
even know yet what I can create but
that's my goal and if I can't get the
information I should actually just start
solving the problem that's right in
front of me right yeah and and I think
those some of the problems are more
concrete like I know you're a big
Twitter user so am i so imagine that you
love Twitter but you hate certain
features in the Twitter app absolutely
for me like you know I get really
distracted by notifications I feel like
if there could be something like a
minimalist Twitter I would love to pay
for that app and use that client instead
but because Twitter is a company and and
and the information that they're sitting
on only they can use it it's not a
marketplace it's not like developers in
go and build different clients that are
compatible with the data that twitter
has right and it wasn't like this in the
beginning like in the early days of
Twitter there were
like some other clients available some
of them are better than the actual
Twitter app and one by one either they
got acquired by Twitter or got shut down
same with the meerkat versus periscope
thing right so meerkat was his app that
was going viral on Twitter and Twitter
bought a competitor periscope and then
shut down access to meerkat and and I
think that's kind of like speaks to the
problem that we have today with a few
big companies having a monopoly on
innovation got it so let's talk about
this idea of decentralization right and
what what when you think of that
what does that mean to you in today's
world right so you've talked a little
bit about these walled gardens that
major Internet companies have around
their data and their social graphs etc
but when somebody says to you you know
why are you working on a decentralized
world you know what's your answer to
that and then kind of go from there yeah
so I think this just this word
decentralization it's not very clear to
the broader audience like what it means
and more importantly like why would they
care right so like sometimes I try to
have the conversation in terms of
ownership rights or freedom of choice
like those are things that I think
people understand better so if you ask
someone that would you like to own
property and let's say you own a house
and you can put all of your belongings
there the answer would be yes I would
like to have like people understand that
property rights are a good thing and
countries where you don't have property
rights they are usually struggling with
you know some sort of a dictator doing
generally bad things to the population
and I think similarly people understand
that freedom of choice is a good thing
right so if there are ten different
competing products for the same thing
usually it's better for the consumer and
they have the freedom of choice that
they can stop using one product and
start using something else and
decentralization to me is a combination
of both these things right when you have
ownership of your information your data
or even software that you downloaded
it's yours now combined with freedom of
choice in the sense that there
there aren't like big monopolies who
control access to information and
developers are basically competing on
the quality of their products when they
want to convince you that you should
download my product or buy my product so
the more competition there is and the
more more freedom of choice there is for
consumers that's generally a better
thing do you think that there's a
diminishing set of returns in terms of
if there's one Twitter and we're all
using it whether it's the best product
that we could possibly find or not the
value we get from the social network or
the social graph and that lock-in cannot
be replicated if all of a sudden you
know there's 15 different Twitter's
everyone's using a different one and
we're not able to actually interact to
get the same amount of content like how
do you what's that trade-off look like I
think there are two things there let me
comment on the first one Chris Dixon
actually wrote a really interesting post
about how internet services generally
which are free are net beneficial for
everyone right so they're providing a
free service users are getting some
utility out of it and the service is
growing and it's a net positive for
everyone but at some point it kind of
like tips over where now they're in the
business of knowing more and more about
you and and usually most of these things
are powered by ads right so at some
point it tips over where the service is
actually becoming harmful for the user
and it the relationship between the user
and the service kind of changes right so
that's one thing that I feel like most
companies that are providing a free
service and monetizing user data kind of
like go through that curve mm-hmm
keeping that context in mind I'm going
to switch over to the actual question
and and that seems to me that hey can a
single company build a better product at
a market and I think I am of the view
that if you open up something to a
broader market the market would
generally deliver a better product all
right so it's not about having
disconnected networks that there would
be like 50 different Twitter's it's
about having some sort of a common
decentralized graph that everyone can be
a part of but they can publish their
products on the same
work and users all of them can be part
of the same network without being users
of any single company got it very
interesting in so happen is power in the
traditional sense plane - that's right
so when you describe these walled
gardens let's say that the the large
Internet companies today they've got a
lot of power right they they set the
rules you can choose to play by the
rules or not and there's not necessarily
a great second option right and so if
you want to connect with people all over
the world and with real identity and be
able to chat with them and posed and
interact with businesses etc Facebook
one of the best ways to do that right
because they have that mass buy it right
or the mass social graph
how does power change when you move to
the decentralized world by the people
who create these products right are they
still the ones that you think will set
the rules and and I really kind of drive
the conversation or do or do you see
some other power mechanism that plays
out so I think first we should like try
to understand how much power these
companies actually have right because
like we started back in like 2013 2014
and back then this was not a common
conversation that people would have they
would be like hey what's wrong with
Facebook or what's wrong Google and at
that time like sometimes I would say
that Oh
Facebook has this campaign where anyone
who's using in their they were giving
out free internet service in India
mm-hmm but you could only use Facebook
and anything that your friends have
shared on Facebook you can access that
but nothing else so a result was that
people thought that Facebook is the
internet right and people would find it
interesting but there wouldn't be
alarmed by it and just to clarify so I
worked at Facebook at 14 and 15 right
and what I think you're describing is
this idea that they were trying to give
access right to the Internet and if I
remember correctly they were subsidizing
the call the data cost right so if you
downloaded there a specific app for this
you could get on and I think it was like
you could access Facebook I get the feed
etc and then I think that there was
maybe some partner websites that if you
know there was like a Wikipedia link in
the Facebook feed you could click and
and that you
see that but you couldn't go outside of
the other partner websites and then I
think their pitch to the data providers
or the cell phone companies was hey
actually this is a great way to onboard
people into using the internet and if
they want to leave this enclosed you
know ecosystem they'll then buy a data
you know package from you right and then
they're off to the races and so it was
an interesting experiment that they did
right with you know kind of various
outcomes depending on the geographic
region and what perspective you have on
you know what would automate their goal
should have been yeah I think their
arguments on both sides that one
argument is that they're giving people
of free service that they would never
have access to otherwise right and
they're getting access to so much
information yeah the other argument is
that hey they're seeing a walled garden
and they're actually not seeing the full
picture and and it what kind of control
Facebook would have down down the road I
think they got into some trouble with
the Indian government on the program and
and so on but I think generally the
concept of you know one company having
that much control over access to
information people wouldn't would find
it interesting but they wouldn't think
that this is something that they should
be concerned about
absolutely until the u.s. election
happen right and where now there's a
serious concern that can Facebook
actually manipulate people's perceptions
to the extent of you know impacting even
results of an election and that's
something that people are generally
concerned about to the extent that now
Mark Zuckerberg is sitting in the
Congress testifying and and it's a it's
a very different world right and there
are certain things like I think Mark
Zuckerberg send a message to Facebook
users and then retracted it that people
don't really understand the gravity of
what that kind of power means like
imagine if the US government was able to
retract some emails from all the inboxes
of the citizens I think there would be
an outcry that how can the government do
this like this email was in my inbox how
can they remove it without my permission
but Mark Zuckerberg basically did an
equivalent of that on the Facebook
network and
people aren't really noticing it so I
think my general point is that the
amount of power that large tech
companies have on users is largely
underestimated right now what would it
be fair to say that so I think there's
enough academic studies now that show if
you show certain types of information to
somebody right not only can you affect
their political leanings they're you
know they're kind of thoughts on certain
issues but but also you can affect their
mental health
you know exception right would it be
fair to compare that to let's say twenty
thirty fifty years ago with traditional
media and newspapers right so let's say
for example that if facebook shows me a
bunch of right or left leaning articles
right versus if I have a subscription to
The New York Times and there's a bunch
of right or left leaning articles what's
the difference there yeah I think it
basically comes back to freedom of
choice and in my view like I I grew up
in Pakistan when I was a teenager we had
a single TV channel that was
state-sponsored and it was a very
interesting learning for me when I grew
up and found out that the version of
history talked to me was actually not
correct right and and and if you if you
go back to Pakistan now people have
freedom of choice like there are so many
private channels and they can choose to
subscribe to whatever they want to
subscribe to but in general once you
have freedom of choice it fee things
become less manipulative right like or
your the power of any single entity it
reduces and that's the entire point of
decentralization right decentralisation
doesn't mean that no one is in control
but the number of it there are a number
of entities instead of just a single
entity and and going back to your
earlier question about what happens in
this world I think people need to think
hard about basically structures or
points of power in even decentralized
networks and ecosystems because it's not
that you just introduced a blockchain
and magically you know we are now living
in a fairy tale there are very very
complicated issues which we don't have
answers to right now a lot of projects
either are already struggling or will
struggle with these problems like before
any of them actually takes off and and
has mass market adoption absolutely so
I'm gonna push you on this idea of
choice cuz that because I agree with you
that without choice right there is a
whole can of worms that I think a lot of
people have a hard time arguing that no
choice is good right I would argue that
you choose to use Facebook and then once
you create an account right you choose
who you connect with both from
individuals media sites that you know
you like their page people that you
follow etc you do not choose the rank of
the algorithmic feed right and you do
not choose the actions with which your
friends take that could also put content
into your feed right so that you know
Mooney liked this post whatever shows up
my feet
where's the line and can we draw a line
right at any point where we say choice
matters up until this point and after
this point you're using a private
company's service and they you know they
have kind of free rein at post this
point right like that that choice that
you could draw a line in the sand on is
blurred to me right and I don't know how
you think about it you know kind of it
from this view yeah so I think just the
first point here is a choice between
different companies that hey can there
be Facebook or something else and I
think a big problem with tech is that a
lot of these large networks tend to be
winner-takes-all market I absolutely
agree so I think that's the first issue
where we we get stuck that this is not a
market where this would be the case that
AT&T if AT&T is successful it would just
take out all of the competitors and it's
the monopolistic nature of a social
network right is if you get enough users
you reach mass adoption the lock-in is
too strong that you don't get value by
joining a separate network because
nobody's there yeah right same with
Google right the more users are using
the search engine the
better data they have on the users and
the Paradise Earth and so I think there
are these inherent winner-take-all kind
of dynamics that are intact that we need
to acknowledge that you know this is the
new world the next thing would be I
think that's a great question that where
do you draw the line I would say that
just like on the when the internet was
starting and there were certain things
that were kind of like part of the core
DNA one of them is that ISPs cannot
differentiate between different types of
traffic which is which is absolutely the
net neutrality thing and you know now
it's not exactly they're in the same
format anymore but still people are
aware of it and they feel that it's a
right that they should have a nice piece
should not be able to differentiate
between traffic I think similarly that
thing didn't happen for the application
layer of the internet like there was no
concept of kind of like a universal
login that you have or some sort of a
social graph that you have that you can
take anywhere to any application right
so it's not very easy for you to exit
Facebook whereas it's very easy for you
to exit an ISP and just get a different
connection absolutely so I think
defining some of those like core
components that belong to the user and
actually don't belong to the company is
something that we never got around to
doing well you and what you're
describing is the incentives for the
company are not in alignment with the
incentives for the individual right
because the incentives for the company
is to get that flywheel started get
adoption of their network start building
that out lock people in right and what
you're essentially describing here is
that works and that helps that company
build and while they're using that data
to make the service better more
enjoyable you know provide better
quality and accuracy etc it's a good
thing but at some point you do hit that
diminishing return right and so if you
do not have aligned incentives from the
beginning there's some period of time
where individuals are willing to
sacrifice there and said that's what
their value for
the value that they're receiving from a
network right but once with that
diminishing return it catches their
attention wait my the incentives here
are misaligned and therefore I think
that's what we're seeing at some of
these large internet companies people
saying I don't know I no longer want to
be entered into this contract that I
have with you as a service but there is
an another option because you locked us
all in yeah and I feel like another big
trend that I'm noticing is with
introduce our tech in general people
have this mentality of trust by default
right so they would just like trust
everything by default unless something
goes wrong and and and that's playing
out in terms of people are not realizing
how much power some of these tech
companies that have like I'm using an
iPhone and it's mind-boggling if you
think about it that this is such a
powerful computer I cannot just like
write a new program and run it on this
computer
it's like fairly locked down like
absolutely can't even like remove apps
from my device or just not allow them on
the App Store even big companies like
uber I think there was a famous incident
where Apple threatened uber that will
just kick you out of the App Store and
uber had to comply like like it's a it's
a 80 billion dollar company and it can
just disappear like this because another
bigger fish says that I I have so much
control that I can decide that you can
no longer be on on on the devices of
people yeah it's a platformer it's great
I mean look we Facebook Apple that they
all have this right so part of the
business model is when people build
these technology services or products on
top of them
right there is that risk that at some
point they can change the rules they can
require you to adhere to certain
criteria that maybe wasn't part of you
know the initial agreement and so it's a
risk right but let's fast forward right
so I I think that it's fairly well
understood now that look there's issues
that companies are going through do you
believe that the current iterations of
these large internet companies are one
going to be able to identify hey these
are real problems right and then to
course-correct
and figure out how to change
in order to not only one solve the
problems but to create a better value
prop for users with better aligned
incentives moving forward or do you
think they have to get disrupted I think
is very unlikely why it is it is likely
that they start realizing that this is a
problem they might start addressing the
problem in their own way it's like for
example I think there was some effort
from Facebook and a couple of other
companies to have some sort of a common
format in which they can like people can
extract the data out and stuff like that
but at the end of the day this is a
business decision so I always try to
imagine a Facebook board meeting where
there's a board approval to kill the
Facebook business model right and that's
a very unlikely event that Facebook just
say is that hey we're going to stop
monetizing and your data at all
it is possible given you know how Mark
Zuckerberg has been really good at
identify but then potential threats to
the company and then proactively going
after them it is possible that they try
to do the same thing with these crypto
based networks and try to establish
themselves as a large player in the
ecosystem so that's that's one
possibility where they can come out
ahead
absolutely not I think that's fair and
to your point I think that a number of
these executives that have faced you
know these issues obstacles you know
crisis before they and their teams have
done a pretty good job of navigating it
right that's how they get to you know
these big powerful positions and this is
another obstacle has a little bit of
nuance to it right but it will be very
interesting to see how they you know
deal with this moving forward what um so
let's keep fast-forwarding here and so
whether those large internet companies
are successful or not what does the 30
to 50 year out view look like in terms
of you know your view of the world of
decentralizing a lot of this power etc
has come to fruition what changes in the
everyday life of you know humans in
terms of how they interact with
technology that's it that's an
interesting question like I feel like if
you would have said
what does it look like 10 years from now
you might have heard positive things
when I started thinking about like 40 to
50 years from now well start n start
with 10 first then we'll go to 40 or 50
sure so I think like 10 years from now I
think is I'm really hopeful that we are
able to solve the problems that we
created in the last four years okay so
it's like one of those things that
technology creates problems and then you
know there's new technology that tries
to solve this problem the thing about
the the 30 to 40 year timeline is that
I'm very concerned about the problems
that the new technology is going to
create okay so before it's a 34 years in
ten years what has changed admire your
life with the way that we our
relationship with technology right is it
that we're using you know a facebook
like you know a social network able to
call a car from our phone you know all
the stuff but it's just there's no
centralized company that's behind it or
what what is different I'm gonna put on
my lens of kind of like an Internet
infrastructure
researcher and answer the question that
way that I think that there were there
are certain problems with the
traditional internet I think of that as
like like take the analogy of a building
that there were some structural flaws
with it and we just decided to duct-tape
it around and decide which is work with
those things for decades and now but the
new capabilities that we have we might
be able to actually address those
problems and those problems are like for
example you know there's a company
Verisign that everyone blindly trust
whenever you see that green lock sign
you know most of the time it's a single
company saying trust me you're talking
to the right right party or you know
when I'm sending a message to my friend
on Facebook it's not really a private
communication it's not like I'm taking a
walk with my friend and that's a
conversation between just me and my
friend Facebook engineers can take a
look at it any government agencies can
take a look at it any hackers that hack
that information can take a look at it
right so some of those like very
fundamental things that we don't have a
concept of
like some sort of user credentials that
are truly owned by users that can be
reused online anywhere like this this
entire concept of like creating
passwords everywhere resetting them
things getting hacked all the time
these honey pots of data so the the
companies are basically creating these
honey pots of data because there's no
better way right if users can actually
keep all that data in a reliable way
with themselves and give access to some
app on a need basis that's a much better
security model in general than seeing
all these hacks that happen all the time
so basically like these base these
Internet infrastructure problems where
we could have done things in a different
way but we didn't and now we are kind of
like trying to handle the the
consequences of that I feel very hopeful
that over a 10-year timeline and
especially given the amount of capital
that's flowing in to some of these crazy
decentralized projects some of them
would take off and actually end up
upgrading the internet to something that
we kinda like always deserve the thing
I'm fearful of is in the process of
doing that like when cloud computing was
starting I remember I was a undergrad I
was really excited about the technology
at that time we did not think about all
these byproducts all these negative
externalities that came with that
technology and the same might happen
with blockchains and crypto there are
things that we are we are just not
afraid enough of absolutely so in that
10-year time frame where I as a user I
own my data right and if I want to use a
service I can basically permission them
to access maybe all of my data or some
subset of my data
one thing I've thought a lot about is
rather than go the universal basic
income right way of if automation
actually exists and humans start to lose
their job the government would have to
pay right to basically allow them to
survive if I own my data just like at a
job when I create value I'm compensated
for that value
if a service wants my data and they pay
me for the ability to use my data you
one have a more secure more user centric
data model and two is you're now solving
some of the socio-economic issues that
could potentially occur with you know
the the the adoption of these
technologies right how likely do you
think that scenario is versus that's
more of a you know a utopia view of the
world from from a technologist
perspective
no I I think it's actually very likely
and there are two points here the first
point is if you look at the general
perception of tech and Silicon Valley I
think any anyone would agree that it the
images off like these companies have a
lot of money people who are early in
tech actually ended up doing really well
for themselves but if you look at all
the users they pretty much have a
miserable life looking at all these ads
that are being shown to them all the
data that that is being tracked and
monetized and they don't really have a
stake in that economy right absolutely
so in a way their data is in a way
highly undervalued and all they're
getting is free products in return for
that whereas that data is actually a lot
more useful plus the market that is
being used for moving all that money
around like if you if you study ad
networks they're like you know nine or
ten different parties and Walt before a
single ad is even shown to a users it's
a fairly inefficient market right if you
can make this a more efficient market
where someone wants to show you a piece
of information and is willing to pay you
for your time I think that kind of
models would evolve in the next five to
ten years and it's a it's a it's a model
where these internet users now become a
part of the economy nicer so they they
can actually earn some of the value as
well and I think a second point is is a
little bit more high level that just
like we are now realizing that attention
is one of our most scarce resources I
think in general
with a more decentralized world in a
world where people start valuing the the
value of their own data right they would
start valuing their attention as well
that that all these advertisers out
there are all these companies maybe they
want me to take certain actions or they
want me to watch something or whatever
it would be that's valuable to someone
else in the economy if I'm giving them
my attention I can actually monetize
that right so I think we we would end up
broadening the economy as a whole and
make the introducers a part of that
economy got it and so it's very
interesting
fast forward more were now in the 4050
year you know timeframe what does that
world look like and what scares you
about it there are a lot of things
that's going to start off I think this
is like one of those things where you
know some people think that oh this is
like you know too late in crypto the
ship has already sailed and and and my
view is that it is just too early in
crypto right now and what I'm scared of
is actually that the people even the
first million or 2 million 5 million 10
million that's a very small number
compared to the rest of the population
right if you look at some of these
distributions that are happening with a
bit tokens they favor early adopters a
lot more than we have seen in other
industries absolutely right so if you
imagine this world 50 years down the
road eh you're joking about Bitcoin
becoming the reserve currency of the
world there's a there's some probability
that that might actually end up
happening I'm just trying to imagine
that some people being rewarded just
because they accidentally they happen to
discover a technology before someone
else right so that's a that's a
troubling thought hold on to questions
here so one what do you think the
probability 50 years out Bitcoin is
a let's say major global currency or the
global reserve currency where would you
put that probability number at right now
just from the top of my head I would say
like five to six percent that is the
number that keeps coming up so that
makes sense and then a lot of people use
this you know notion that because
somebody is early they're lucky right
and I think that many of the people who
are early say they were lucky right and
so it kind of gets okay put on the shelf
we both agree and we move up in the
conversation but I would challenge that
discovering the technology could be a
moment of luck right you randomly came
across a website a friend and passing
told you about it right there's a whole
bunch of things that are just
serendipitous about discovering the
technology acting on that discovery
right is much more intentional so
whether you start mining you purchase
you know some tokens etc that is more of
a self-directed or self initiated action
and then also the ability to have the
discipline whether by accident because
you forgot that you and the tokens or
whatever or intentionally to hold as
that technology becomes more more
valuable over time it's still somewhat
self-initiated right and so what
percentage of people do you think that
have either already benefited or stand
to benefit in the future
is truly luck versus their serendipitous
you know discovery of the technology but
then they actually take action and they
should be rewarded in some way for that
action no I definitely think that people
deserve a lot of credit it's not that
you just like randomly showed up and we
wish not lucky there are many people who
were early and they ended up like
selling their tokens or they didn't
believe in the technology enough so I
definitely want to give credit where
credit is due you I think my the reason
why I feel uncomfortable is the
dynamics of the distributions in the
sense that if there is a new invention
sure the inventor gets some credit and
ends up making some fortune out of that
and then they're people who kind of like
worked on taking that invention and
commercializing it into the rest of the
world or let's say that you are your kid
and you're becoming an engineer you're
learning about this new technology and
you hope to get a job in that sector
right all of that is a slightly
different model from a purely token
distribution mechanism that here's the
initial distribution we're just locking
it in for the rest of time and without
much thought in most times like when we
were doing our token distribution we
actually like spent you know months and
months like agonizing over how this
should look like and and actually ended
up taking the least amount of tokens for
the project creators are out of like
most major projects out there and that
was one of the reasons for it
but I feel like not we don't even have
the models to actually able to study the
long-term implications of some of these
distributions absolutely III think that
admitting that we don't know yet right
is a big step for a lot of people and
then we've got to really focus on
figuring out because there there's a
there's an intersection of what is right
what is fair and what is economically
sustainable right and so it's not a very
it's not a simple decision and I don't
think we've had enough experience
watching some of the previous attempts
that took a distribution play out to
really know what the impact even is of
those attempts and you should go through
the cycles over a couple of years to
really figure that out yeah and I was
going through the my list of fears and
the next one is interesting that I feel
like because I work in crypto people
sometimes assume that I am against
government's like I might I might have
my personal views on you know
governments are inefficient or they
shouldn't be like too large or this and
that but I think people just assume that
I'm an anarchist I'm not
and at the same time like I feel like
personally I feel like I'm somewhere in
the middle right but we don't realize
the implications that what if
governments cannot collect taxes anymore
right like some people get really
excited about that notion but I'm a
little bit scared by notions like these
that if governments are unable to
collect taxes that means that some sort
of a new structure would have to evolve
for people to self organize in the
physical world and usually when there is
large disruptions like like these there
are like peers even decades of basically
chaos right and we might end up seeing
those periods in a lifetime if this
actually happens right so this is like
one of one of the fears as well and it's
fear of the unknown write it let less
fear of this is what's gonna happen I
don't like that from happening right
it's more of if we do get to a situation
where governments can't collect taxes
what happens I don't know it sounds like
you don't know either right and so that
is scary right I think that's completely
fair I want to go back to something you
said earlier about government in growing
up right and so this idea of a single
channel where you're getting news
history etc and you're getting a very
specific a very political eyes view of
the world what was it from your memory
the first time you realized that there
was other narratives right or other
perspectives on whether it was news
history etc like what do you remember
what that was and kind of walk us
through like what that feeling is like
because I don't think most Americans
ever get to experience that yeah I can I
can share a personal story yeah it's
basically I think one of the first times
that I was out of the country I think it
was I got a paper published somewhere
after my undergrad I was out of the
country it was in Canada somewhere and
there was a cab driver who was from
Bangladesh
and I was being very friendly with him
and I even said something like you know
like like like Pakistan and Bangladesh
or her super close and he just gave me a
weird look and and the the the story
there is that they used to be the same
country with India in the middle and
there was a war
after which Bangladesh was separate from
a country and so my dad he actually
served in the army right so not only
that I have that single state sponsor
channel like my dad and all his friends
also had this view of the wall that the
army sponsored story sponsored story
that you know pockets in Pakistan
actually tried helping Bangladesh but
absolutely India was trying to meddle
around and they and they ended up like
taking parts of our country and made it
like something else and I completely
missed out on that entire story about
how there was a movement by the local
people who were being suppressed to to
actually gain freedom from Pakistan and
the Pakistani army was actually blamed
of genocide right like and this is a
very tricky topic to bring up in my
household I'm not going to like break
like basically have a conversation with
my dad that you were part of this war
absolutely no one ever told me that you
know that there are allegations of
genocide there so I think it's stuff
like that that when when you read
material that where you have the freedom
of choice like I can go and try and read
an Indian author or or a Bangladeshi
author or a neutral party and then a
then a Pakistani author as well like I
think I will end up walking away with a
better understanding of what might have
happened versus if if if you have very
limited sources or limited options but
for me personally that was like you know
I was old enough I was like early
twenties or so that it suddenly made me
start to question any belief that I
helped write then that it's like I
opener that oh no the world is not how
you think it is always beyond go
and always be looking out for things
that you just missed out on and it
assumed that they are certainly there's
a point in most people's life right
where they realize there is a separation
between belief in fact and for the most
part right some of it is just social
control or you know some of it is it's
much easier to teach kids with stories
than you know hey this is the fact but
you grow up believing the stories right
so you have belief in things and this is
everything from religious to you know
Christmas you know all kinds of stuff
right and then when you get the facts it
all a sudden you start to question your
beliefs and then it makes you almost
want more facts right you almost become
addicted to the facts and it's you know
if you tell me every single fact and
then I'll make my own decision right and
I think that one thing that we tend to
here in the United States at a very
Western centric world it's a very you
know nationalistic view of the world
right and so we're presented with a set
of facts but if you take those same
facts and you present them to somebody
somewhere else in the world very
different perspective right and I think
that part of crypto and the beauty of
this is this is a global phenomenon
right that this is technology now
empowering not just access to
information and access to choice but it
is allowing people with very different
perspectives in life to collaborate and
build technology right and so you who
grew up with this state-sponsored
television channel have a view on
certain things that somebody who didn't
grow up with that don't have and so just
the idea the simple idea of a powerful
government being able to dictate a
message has an impact on your views
right and so I think that there are
probably things that you and I believe
today that we don't yet realize are
actually inaccurate or we will evolve
those thoughts as we get presented with
more facts more access to information
and a more global is deep right
absolutely and I think it's it's very
hard to do that right like it's very
hard to always be questioning your own
beliefs because the you also don't want
to cross over and across the line of
paranoia
but I think it's it's generally it's a
healthy thing for your brain if you're
just a little bit on your guard all the
time
absolutely so speaking of that what is
one belief that you have in the crypto
space that you think a high degree of
other people a high number of other
people would disagree with and so it
would be a controversial belief I'm
gonna rephrase that I'm gonna rephrase
you have to answer it too
it's the same question but I'm going to
rephrase is it - what's the one belief
that I had that if I tweet about it
people are gonna start yelling at me
okay perfect so I think that belief is
that regulation might not be bad for the
industry right like it's I think again
all the anarchist and and and people who
are on one end of the spectrum in the
space might might disagree that no this
is why we came to crypto to begin with
and no good can come out of regulations
but I just think that not all
regulations exist like regulations some
of the regulations exist for good reason
and I completely understand that things
become bureaucratic or over a long time
some of the things that needed to exist
50 years ago 100 years ago they might
not make sense today but I think it's a
spectrum and I'm somewhere in the middle
of the spectrum then on either end and I
actually think that where we are today
crypto has such a bad reputation in the
general press that it's actually holding
us back to reach the broad markets and
and just like I'm like a broader user
base because of this clash almost or the
story that is being painted in the media
that here a bunch of anarchists who are
fighting with governments here are a
bunch of people who want to have these
crypto tokens that cannot be taxed or
you know regulators can come down
and scrutinize these projects because
they don't know where the creators are
and so on and so forth I don't think
that's healthy for the ecosystem right
so well give me an example of a piece of
regulation you think would be good for
the industry that maybe other people
would disagree with so I think again I
there's something on which I cannot get
too specific but let's just say that
there's a lot of discussion about
utility tokens mm-hmm that you know
these tokens are like arcade tokens and
you need them to go play an arcade game
right so there is no reasons for
regulators to come in and try and
regulate these tokens because that just
doesn't make sense but I think if you
look at the reality on the ground
usually these tokens are being developed
by a team usually under a corporation
right and without that corporation these
tokens wouldn't be worth anything or the
protocol would never get developed right
so if the regulators are coming in and
asking questions there are good reasons
for doing that right because there is
actually so much bad behavior going on
in the industry in general that it's
it's giving us a bad name
absolutely so I think just because
someone something has a utility and it
looks more like an arcade token doesn't
mean that under certain circumstances
some regulations don't apply yeah the
the example I usually use it and I think
this is what you're saying is so imagine
if somebody wanted to build an arcade
right they said to potential investors
give me money and I will give you arcade
tokens I then take your money and while
you're holding the arcade tokens I go
and I buy a piece of land I start a
business I build a building right I
build out the arcade and on day one I
open the doors and I say hey
congratulations I use your money and I
you know built this business come use
your arcade tokens right the idea that
those arcade tokens are securities when
you're using them probably doesn't fly
right because they're an arcade took
you're using it you're getting
you out of it right all stuff the idea
that you gave me money and I went and I
built all this stuff with it and you
have no ownership right or no claim to I
think is a bad investment opportunity
right and so I think teams have actually
done a pretty good job in terms of in
their documentation sister explicitly
saying you have no ownership this is not
debt you know that they really are
putting the disclaimers in but I think
that where the question becomes is if I
am selling you as a potential investor
these arcade tokens and I don't deliver
on what I said again where is the line
right what what repercussions should you
have even if it is not equity right and
and if you do not have any recourse that
is a huge incentive for bad acting right
because you're basically gave me the
money and I just don't feel like doing
it anymore right
well that's not a good situation for you
and I think that that's where regulators
are really worried about is there's
money transacting or changing hands how
do we protect the people who are giving
up money right in exchange for these you
know arcade tokens etc yeah I think that
that's a great example for the arcade to
converse is actually the act of building
something that starts having a utility
down the road yeah for sure
what um what company do you think is one
of or the most important company to the
kind of sustainability of crypto over
the next you know 10 15 years I feel
like I'm a little bit biased in the
sense that I always end up giving the
answers e cash and file coin basically
I'm pretty close with both suku and Kwan
and and for me the reason is a little
bit like like they understand what the
challenges are and they're pretty much
grounded in both kind of like the
technical limitations and they
understand the the what the enormous
challenge it is to get any of these
things working over a long run and get
them in the hands of millions of people
whereas I feel like
without taking in names usually if I'm
at a crypto and there's a lot of
excitement yep but it's a little bit
disconnected both from technical
realities and market realities right so
I think those two people they have
already done great work and I feel like
that they would continue to do so
got it this is an interesting point we
were really talking about here is
there's the technological success right
so you have to build something that
works and when you do that it really
only matters if people actually use the
the working technology right if you both
some networks and nobody uses it doesn't
really matter if it works or not right I
think in 2016 I raise some red flags on
like scalability of bludgeons like I
said that you know without taking names
there are certain projects out there
that you look at the technology it just
simply does not scale to the extent that
you know it wouldn't even get a million
users on the platform right two years
down the road now I think at least that
challenge is well understood like if
you're in crypto everyone is now yeah
you know block chains don't scale and
now there are a bunch of projects we're
working on it right like some capital
went in people are now trying to solve
that problem like similarly I think
that's just like one particular problem
with one particular layer of what we're
trying to build and there are other
challenges like that that are not
getting enough attention and I usually
have respect for people that that are
aware of those limitations and they're
actually very few absolutely how do you
think the user adoption is gonna play
out for the D apps right so these
decentralized applications that are
being built on top of blockchains
let's say that the technology gets
solved so products work there's a
scalable solution that's in place that
we can go from you know users to
billions of users
how did teams think about that today and
what do you think is gonna be the
successful path to really get that
adoption yep so I think on the
technology slash infrastructure side I
don't think we're there yet I think
we're going to stay in that phase
while so we at block stack of roughly
done like four years of R&D work just on
that problem on the infrastructure
infrastructure scalability specifically
right and we have taken the work we've
done and we've taken it to traditional
distribution systems researchers and
have published that at peer reviews
venues so I feel like fairly confident
that the work that we have done it got
the approval of what I consider the
experts in those particular problems and
and and our new new blockchain would
actually scale out much better than some
of the existing solutions that you would
see out there and and that's not it like
I alluded to this earlier that's not
just the problem at the blockchain there
it's also a discovery like how do you
actually discover if you're not putting
data inside the blockchain you're
putting it somewhere else how do you
discover where that data is and is that
reliable will it scale out if millions
of people are actually trying to now
discover these pointers to two different
location and then persistent storage
right like you get free services from
Google and Facebook what you don't see
is these massive factories and these
massive armies of engineers that they
have started working day and night to
keep that data reliable and and so that
you can access it in a really fast way
and you need to solve those problems in
the dissent lies world but I feel
confident that you know in the next year
or two
we would start emerging from this
infrastructure phase and the next two
challenges in my mind one is you know
this idea of user education and the UX
of these decent sized applications
people have no idea what private keys
are people their tolerance for going
through onboarding steps is not that
high right so it needs to be like super
easy for anyone to sign up it needs to
be super easy for people to understand
like what my credentials are how can I
reuse them what happens if I lose access
everyone's used to just saying like hey
forgot my password sent me a new those
are those are some like classic things
that everyone talks about but I feel
like one thing that we don't talk about
that much is what's the utility of the
decent lies apps right like is it just
the fact that
it's decent lies okay so what I always
tell people all the time would I say
just because it's decentralized doesn't
mean anyone cares right and and would
you agree that you have to if you want
to displace facebook with a
decentralized version you have to build
a better Facebook that also is
decentralized or do you think that the
decentralization with a comparable
product is enough to get people to move
I think it has to be equal or better
equal or better okay but some
functionality that Facebook cannot give
you today
right and that functionalities actually
gives utility to people interesting that
makes sense and so in this decentralized
world right how do you think about
leadership right so I'll give you an
example a theorem right is considered a
decentralized Network there's plenty of
people who I'm sure will yell at us for
even mentioning that and just by people
who will agree with us but Vitalik right
is seen as a leader if not the leader of
this network and so there is still some
single points of centralization even if
it might not be in true governance right
but but he is the leader how does that
evolve over time if we're gonna build
truly decentralized networks do we
always have to have a suit Anonymous
leader like it with Bitcoin and Satoshi
or is there a world where kind of
leadership as we know it today can
interact with these decentralized
networks and that's okay yeah so one
thing I've seen in open source products
in general this is outside of crypto
that generally the concept of a
benevolent dictator ends up working
pretty well like someone that has
authority not because of any anything
legal or social capital like just
because of their social capital or
people believing in what that person is
saying it tends tends to work out pretty
well
it's lost the that's like market
pressure on the technology where you
could fork it and and something else can
happen right so and those are like
checks and balances on the on the
leadership team
and I think like in general the
trade-offs are that if you are a startup
you know not a crypto startup like
straight-up traditional company with a
strong leadership you can actually move
fast you can build things absolutely and
and there are a lot lots of benefits for
that and on on one side you know you
have cases like Bitcoin no one knows who
Toshi is or a group like who those
people are and then at the same time you
know they are so decent lies that it's
very hard for them to agree on any
single thing there are benefits of that
approach and maybe for what bitcoin is
trying to do that's the right approach
for that technology but I think in
general you my view is that you need
certain organizations in an ecosystem
that have strong leaders and that can
actually move fast and build stuff but
because there are multiple organizations
and multiple parties with different
amounts of control and power that keeps
like a check and balance on any single
entity in that ecosystem I think that
makes sense and you can almost have
different types or you can have the
centralized companies the decentralized
companies and if you build the entire
ecosystem correctly they coexist and are
both successful right yeah and speaking
of ecosystem I think that's a change in
mindset that a lot of people need to
have like also like entrepreneurs who
are thinking of starting companies there
you really need to start thinking about
how to build an ecosystem and not how to
build the startup you will actually find
a lot of advice out there from you know
Silicon Valley or VCS about how to build
a company I don't think there's any
advice out there about how to build
thriving ecosystems and that is
something that people start seeing more
and more and when you talk about
ecosystem there's more about the
community and the networks and all these
things that tie in around a project that
can help make it successful yeah I mean
again let's take a theorem for example
there are many companies there's
consensus here in New York there's the
etherium Foundation there are the
battery people and then there are other
companies who started like either theory
Mavin's or started consulting
with different governments there people
who actually poured a lot of capital
into it and many people who formed funds
and their developers who started
building smart contracts or applications
on top of it here and these are like
different entities but they all kind of
meet need each other right so if someone
is trying to design a kind of like a
crypto ecosystem you would end up having
similar needs that you need capital
sources you need developers you need
people to build on your platform and
then your platform itself needs to be
decentralized so there might be multiple
entities that are needed to actually
contribute to the core platform those
are very different challenges from hey I
want to start a company I'm gonna hire
an executive team I'm gonna hire
engineers right like so that's that's
something I feel like where we as an
industry would evolve and best practices
might emerge or people might start you
know passing guidelines to younger
entrepreneurs and so on just like we
what happened in Silicon Valley in the
late 90s and so on yeah the transfer of
information experience right is super
important what um what do you do on a
daily or a weekly basis that you think
is well important in terms of forming
your opinions about the space I feel
like I'm actually this is a personal
thing that I've been actively trying to
disconnect from everything like this is
it might sound stupid that when I tweet
I have to first install the Twitter app
I tweet and then I delete the app what
why why that explain that I I just I
just can't take the notifications I
can't take the feed and there's no other
way of doing this and in general what
I've noticed is that we are just like
hyper connected all the time and we are
not even realizing it so even if I it's
all like I'm I'm going somewhere and
having like sitting in a corner having
deep thoughts about the industry just by
disconnecting actually sometimes give
you a better perspective when you come
back
or when somebody tells you that oh this
happened and that happened if you were
not like too deep in the day-to-day and
like something might appear strange to
me which might not appear strange to me
if I was like very actively
participating and everything and it's
like oh yeah everyone's doing it this
way right so I don't know if it's a good
strategy but it's a strategy that I've
been have been trying to apply for the
last six or eight months is it just
Twitter or they're out like is it kind
of technology in general no I I don't
read any news I hate unsubscribed from
every single thing it's also about like
like just generally I try to minimize
information flow coming to me and there
are people at blocks AK you know if
there's a lunch conversation going on I
would just pick up on something and just
hear their version of what's going on
absolutely has that change your
perception of the accuracy of the news
right so if you used to let's say read
the news every day and you're kind of
following a story or some sort of trend
you know at detail versus you know
you're at lunch and you hear just that
one conversation and it's coming from
somebody that you know what's the
difference they're right in terms of
like how you perceive that information
yep I think that made me realize that
for that approach to work you need to
surround yourself with really really
good people right so it's like so Jude
Nelson he's he did a PhD with me at
Princeton as well and he's one of the
core developers on block stack and I
feel like I get summaries of what other
projects are doing from him but because
I trust him blindly like I I know that
this ten minute 15-minute conversation
would fill me in on like 60 70 percent
of what that project is up to and if I'm
interested I can like take take a deeper
dive myself but absolutely like if
you're relying on other people for
information then who those people are
become extremely extremely important
absolutely that makes sense what's been
your biggest surprise over the last
three four years that you guys have been
than building in the space in terms of
you know what's already occurred right
what happened that you didn't expect I
think a lot of people in crypto kind of
take this recent uptick in prices and
the amount of capital that came in as
like oh we always knew that was going to
happen but taking a long enough timeline
I think we should take a moment to
appreciate that open-source software
never got any funding researching new
protocols never got any funding like I
remember writing a hundred page grant
application for the for the NSF for
something like I think 400 K out of
which 60% would have gone to Princeton
as overhead for managing the grant and
so you're roughly talking about like a
hundred K to go off and do research on
new protocols mm-hmm right
whereas if you look at the number of
projects were coming up with ambitious
new ideas and people are just throwing
money at and like real capital where to
the extent that you know some of the
projects I was indeed having discussion
but who on about potentially funding
research centers like we are at a
position where we can actually fund
actual research at top universities
right I think taking a moment to realize
that just two years ago there was a
event decent-sized Web Summit that
recently happened in San Francisco and
it's a by the Internet Archive guys and
they did a great job of like inviting
Sir Tim berners-lee windsurf like some
of the actual internet fathers and
putting them in the same room as some of
these crypto projects and they did the
same thing in 2006 16 as well and I was
just remembering that in 2016
Zee cash didn't launch right suku was
still working on least Authority and
and transitioning to Z cash corn with
Falcon and us we were both graduates of
Y Combinator from 2014
we both had seed rounds of like roughly
like a million dollars it's a very small
project just two years ago and then
something happened that's here where
there was this like crazy amounts of
capital coming into the ecosystem so
many projects starting so many people
getting interested and and I don't think
that the the industry deserved it or
that we earned it it's something that
has happened and I think we need to take
a moment to realize that we should be
grateful and we should try to act
responsibility for what we would do with
this opportunity that we have now very
interesting it's a last question for you
what is nobody working on but you think
needs to get built
I think there's a lot of talk of you
know the decent lies web and different
projects kind of like have their own
disconnected Internet's almost right and
I don't see an effort where someone is
trying to build either like a search
engine that goes across all these
different sources and gives a unified
experience to the end user like imagine
like what the early search engines like
you know Alta Vista did for the early
internet users like that they were the
Gateway to all the information right so
it's a search engine that looks up
information on let's say if it's on ipfs
or swarm or block stack or anywhere else
and becomes kind of like a window for
these new users I I don't think I've
seen a project a true index where you
can even actually get discovery that
makes sense man all right you can ask me
one question and then and then we'll end
this thing up I have a very basic
question like I feel like you appeared
on Twitter as like a storm and suddenly
you know it's it's it's very hard to
actually avoid thoughts coming from you
like how did you get into this ecosystem
but more importantly like what was
what's what drives you because that one
thing I appreciate about you is that
your tweets are always like full of
energy right like this so my question is
always like you know what drives you and
how did you get into this yeah so
getting into it
we were Osage investing and we started
to see more and more founders that
wanted to start companies looking at the
space looking at technology and the aha
for me was a one or two of our companies
had some of their top talent leave and
so you fund a company and next thing you
know you know whatever top engineer
leaves you're like what's going on that
I don't know right and it was less about
they were running from something and
they were running to something right so
somebody early on it told me you know
follow the talent follow the money and
so we started looking and this is
2016 or so right I'm kind of beginning
to have 16 and we just kind of like I
don't get how an investor plays in this
space and it really was coming down to a
lot of the investment opportunities at
the time where they were picking up
where these icos and so that you know
going back to that arcade example I
didn't want to give people money for
them to go buy the land build the
building build the business and then I
just can go use the arcade tokens and so
we start out mining right and this idea
that I'm very familiar with the data
center business and so that I could take
a piece of hardware stick it in a space
put power and then have a subscription
cash flow model and not deal with
customers right it was super interesting
right because it's basically better
mining or a better data center business
and so as we started to build that it
was in hindsight very valuable but we
didn't plan for it to be because it
allows you to then discover the rest of
the ecosystem so the example I uses well
if you're mining then you've got to ask
yourself what do I do with the tokens
well I gotta get a wallet rights okay
where do I get a wallet and then once
you get the tokens in the wallet should
I sell them into Fiat should I hold them
in what I'm mining should I diversify
well what are my other options right so
you start discovering other projects and
you kind of just slowly you know in a
very serendipitous way discover a lot of
this stuff I don't know if that's
possible if you start on kind of the
opposite end of the spectrum right if
you start from the liquid tokens etc for
us it was very natural to start it but
really the base layer of the
infrastructure right and come up I wish
that we could say that we meant to do
that
right but we didn't and so I think that
that was an interesting way to do it and
and through most of 16 I didn't have
enough confidence to talk intelligently
about a lot of it rikes I think that it
was one of these things where okay I
know they were mining and I get that
business because we're doing it but
could I really describe in detail what
that machine is doing probably not right
and so I think that once I started to
gain that confidence of talking about it
I'd tweet once tweet twice right and
then I realized oh wow people care about
this right and you see the engagement
etc and
and all of a sudden I just said look I
think that we're gonna spend a bunch of
time here and let's really double down
right and so the stuff on Twitter was
really a lot of people in the space of
technologists they speak at an
incredibly intelligent level with it but
it's a lot of jargon right it's a lot of
kind of deep thoughts etc and I said I'm
not technical like that but I had just
enough intelligence where I think I can
understand the high-level concept I
can't I can't hang with the engineer and
describe it in detail but I get the
concept and if I can take that concept
and I can share it I bet you there's a
bunch of people like me out there who
would love to understand you know these
concepts at a high level and how they
apply to their world right and so when I
started sharing that I think that kind
of drew a bigger audience and then the
the really kind of tipping point for me
was understanding it sounds very similar
to you that you don't have to be an
anarchist to believe that a lot of this
will happen right and actually there is
a freedom to saying what everyone else
is thinking right so I I really do
credit a lot of you know kind of on
Twitter so if you see the things that
everyone engages with you know these
tweets I explode because I'm just saying
what people think right and so the the
the one that always cracks my partner's
up is when I say the currency of choice
of you know money launderers terrorists
criminals around the world is a u.s.
dollar well that's just an aggregate
data based fact right and you can make
data say whatever you want you know and
all stuff but a lot of people who
actually believe that right cuz it's
true and so when you say it they're like
wow I can't believe he said that
and then they engage with it it takes
off and so the flip side or the negative
side of that is there are a lot of
things I want to say right now a lot of
things you want to say and so you do
learn to you know say a lot of it but
there's some things that just you know
not worth saying but but I do think that
that AHA around twitter really drove a
lot of the growth and the engagement
and you know frankly Twitter's probably
been the best tool for when I put these
ideas out I mean you know I'm sure just
like you I get people who absolutely
love it and they agree and they think
it's you know this great idea I get
people who literally think that I'm an
idiot and it's the dumbest thing they've
heard on Twitter and then they tweet
that at me right you're an idiot and
that's the dumbest thing I've heard
today and so what it does is it allows
these ideas to go through like some
attrition right and really kind of get
beat up and see where your beliefs are
once you watch all these different
people respond and then it's a lot of
people right so you know people will
reach out and say hey I saw you said
this right I disagree I agree and all
stuff and so it is it's a very
interesting way of engaging on a topic
but but I think that my thoughts have
evolved a little bit of like Twitter and
the Internet in this decentralized world
is a little bit like a coffee shop right
it's rather than in you know the 90s and
early 2000s in Silicon Valley everyone
goes the same coffee shop and they talk
and there's all these exchanges of ideas
and you know collision of people and
relationships etc well now everyone for
the most part you know if you're a user
of Twitter you get the opportunity to
participate in that to some degree which
I think is powerful but it allows people
to go from you know completely off the
map to well connected very quickly yep
and just to go back full circle on how
I've been consuming information these
days this actually came up in those
lunch conversations where someone
brought up you know something you said
on Twitter someone else brought up on a
different day I'm like wait a minute
who's this guy and then she went and
looked but it's been a pleasure
it was great connecting with you on
Twitter absolutely well hopefully at
least one of them said I was smart the
other said I was stupid so you got both
both sides of the argument there no I
mean but but thank you so much for
coming I really appreciate this I think
that you know hopefully this was helpful
to a lot of people and you've got a very
unique view of the world so so keep
going because I think a lot of us for
chair for you awesome thank you so much
like this is fun